mon blake m franchement terre l'amour
merci je m'exclus télé que l'ex
totalement ça y est j'ai l'impression
que tout le monde est dans le clip assez
un truc donc tout le monde est dans le
fil pas vraiment mais ça y est l'un qui
siphonnaient les voir ou non mais facile
face il fallait prévoir et chérie jamais
qu'elle évoquait un mac à les voir on
peut tous faire un amazigh regarder ses
messages tout vas-y vas-y vas-y je peux
twitté il est twitter je vais écrire je
kiffe black m voici n'hésite pas m'ont
plaqué mme black m
éternel insatisfait c'est nouvel album
yes c'est l'album de black et bien sûr
que vous connaissez le clip est tendue
depuis évité
merci d'avoir été avec nous sur ces vite
tout de suite c'est rocky balboa merci
black and avoir été avec nous mais
restait sur ses visites au vous êtes
fort et n'oubliez pas la télé c'est que
de la télé merci je suis tout seul
ils sont tous figés 26 ont permis
d'émissions comme ça s'allume et chéri
joe